in this tutorial we're going to build on
the previous primal video I made which
is called primal active site in minutes
now you might be sitting there eating a
sandwich or passively wanting to watch a
primal video but the best way to learn
this is to open a primal window yourself
and work through with me pausing when
you need a minute to type commands and
sort through things so I highly
recommend that and let's get to it we're
gonna fetch our structure the structure
we're going to work with today is
phosphofructokinase one pfk when you
pull this up your view will look
something like this although it might
not quite look like this some versions
of Pinal when you pull it up
it looks like this so you're looking at
one of those two views and now we're
gonna all get ourselves to the same view
using a preset in Pinal so if we go to
the a actions preset and this structure
does have water molecules it has solvent
but we're gonna just do pretty with it
for now we'll work with the solvent
later so click on pretty and now we
should all be looking at this nice
little cartoon rainbow with our ligands
shown as sticks so that's a pretty nice
place to start
let's reorient this structure a little
bit so we can kind of see it make it
look nice yeah I like that and let's
store this as our first scene so scenes
are up here you can store up to 12 just
using the drop-down menus over here or
we can type scene 0:01 store Comus store
and that will give us a scene which
shows up right here now I think by
typing this you can store many more
scenes than twelve so that's nice if you
really want to get going with a complex
structure and have lots of scenes to
move around in
now let's display our sequence and I'm
actually using a trackpad I don't use a
three button Mouse like a lot of people
like to for time'll I got really good at
it on a plane so I'm gonna put this in
one button viewing mode and I'm just
using my trackpad I can
use the control option and command
buttons to do different things and I can
zoom by just using my trackpad squeezing
my fingers in and out so here is our
sequence notice it starts off dark blue
so we're starting off here and as we
scroll through you can see the color
changing which corresponds to the
rainbow of this protein as we scroll we
see all of our one letter codes for our
two polypeptide chains of this dimer
which ends at the red over here and then
we have a bunch of ligands so they're
separated out and then all of our water
molecules I find it useful to have a
selection which is just my protein and
so I'm going to click on the end the
c-terminal amino acid residue here come
all the way to the beginning press shift
and click and now I have all the amino
acid residues selected and I'm going to
rename this selection to protein so that
I could operate on the ligands and the
protein separately if I need to later
click somewhere on the black just to
click away no I'm a little bit worried
about having the rainbow here because
you know that's a lot of color to be
behind the ligands and our ligands have
some orange in it and I don't want it to
get confusing so let's go ahead and
color our protein by element and we'll
go ahead and color at this cyan I like
this view let's go ahead and just store
this as another scene
and now let me show you what the scenes
are doing so we're going to click here
we get our different colors so scenes
are storing the color and as we'll see
in a bit they'll store the orientation
for us as well this is really helpful
because you might have noticed my mole
doesn't really undo things very well so
when you make a mistake you really
sometimes end up starting back from
scratch so this is gonna save us a lot
of trouble as long as we're storing our
scenes whenever we make a good one okay
now I want to show an active site I want
to identify an active site we have a
dimer here and we have a lot of ligands
bound to it so let's scroll back down to
our ligands and I just want to focus in
on one active site maybe this top one up
here let's see okay
so I clicked on this these are the
reaction products so it says so in the
title here so this is fructose 1 6
bisphosphate right here and now we want
to identify all the other ligands in
this active site you can see we have
other ligands kicking around here so
let's click on this magnesium oh I can
just barely see it lighting up let me
zoom a little bit for you and on my Mac
I'm gonna click option and click and
that allows me to move my structure so
you see it right here so this one is in
our active site that we want let's click
on this one well maybe I need to zoom
out just to see where everything is now
oh yeah this one is lighting up over
here so that's not one we want
oh that ADP is here ok let's just check
the others yeah these are all in
different parts of the protein so this
is this selection now these three things
that we've clicked have come up as this
selection and let's rename this to
ligands so actions rename selection
delete that s ele over here and type
ligands
great I think you're really gonna like
this next command so last time I had you
showing the residues around the ligand
but we're going to be able to make a
selection in one quick command so this
is the command select active that will
create a selection called active by
residues all within 5 angstroms of and
this is our selection name so whatever
you called this if you decided to call
this something besides ligands you just
change your selection name here so let's
execute this and BAM we've got all the
residues within about 5 angstroms this
catches all of our hydrophobic
interactions and definitely our ionic
and hydrogen bonding so that's that's a
pretty good active site so let's show
the sticks for the active site and then
let's zoom on the active site now
sometimes I like to get a little
contrast between these residues and the
cartoon and so for active let's just go
to our colors and we want to color by
element because we want to keep our CPK
coloring and in set 5 I believe this one
will give me just a little bit darker of
residues so yeah that looks ok yeah and
so we have a little contrast you can see
the color change on the backbone here
now we've done a little bit of work so
let's store this as another scene so our
third scene is here so if we messed up
something along the way we could always
revert back to where we were when we got
here let's just go to the command line
and type show non-bonded and this is
going to show our water molecules we can
see our active site is rich with water
and so if we only show the active site
and look for our interactions we will
miss some because some of these
inevitably are going to be contacts to
water molecules so we might have water
mediated contacts and we don't want to
ignore that so it's wise for us to soul
some of the water molecules but we
really only want to get the ones that'll
be hydrogen bonded to our ligands and
maybe our active site residues also I'm
just noticing that my my ligands are in
blue let's go ahead and color our
ligands by element and choose this
magenta here so we have some contrast
and we could see what's actually going
on here in this active site okay so
here's our command I'm gonna create a
selection called ligand water and do be
careful when you put the underscores in
you will always have to type underscores
when you're typing your selection name
so keeping your selection names short
and without spaces actually is going to
be very helpful if you make them really
short you might just need to write down
a little code that you're using but the
shorter the better if you're gonna use
typed commands so we're gonna select the
water around the ligands so select
ligand water so this is making a
selection called ligand underscore water
which I told you just not to use
underscores but then we're going to use
ligand here which um so actually I think
this needs to be ligands so this is
nearer ligands selection it's going to
be three point two angstroms the length
of a typical hydrogen bond and we're
choosing to show the waters so let's
execute this command and we have a
selection now let's go ahead and I think
at this point let's just show the
spheres and they look really really huge
so this makes sense because this is
actually the Vander Waals surface of the
water molecule but we're not looking at
anything else in that way and we're
going to resize these water molecules
but before we do that I actually want to
get more of the water molecules that are
in the active site I want to get all of
those in range of the active site
residues as well so I changed this
command a little bit select active water
so this is the water around the active
site residues this is the selection I'm
choosing this active here at
same distance and choosing water so we
get a few more highlighting here let's
show Spears and because we're looking at
this all in sticks it makes less sense
to look at the van der Waals surface of
the water so we're going to resize this
the command we're using now is alter
active water to a van der Waals radius
of 0.5 angstroms so I'm gonna type that
nothing's gonna happen at first now I'm
gonna use my arrow keys so if you start
clicking your up and down arrow keys you
can go through all of your previous
commands to alter them so that's really
awesome in Pinal and so I want to make
this ligand water because I want to
alter both of them to that Van der Waals
radius so alter ligand water and then we
need to type rebuild to actually make
the water molecules resize so that's
important to do at the end
okay let's zoom in a little and look
around so yeah we've got lots of waters
we've got a few non-bonded showing up so
I think at this point we probably should
have everything that is in range for a
hydrogen bond as we'll look at in one
moment and so let's go ahead and just
hide non-bonded again so we don't have
all of those little water molecules okay
remember we had a magnesium in our
active site so that's right here and boy
it looks tiny but magnesium actually has
a larger van der Waals surface than the
water molecules let's just click on this
to select it and I'm going to rename it
to magnesium and now let's resize this
so we're going to do a similar thing so
we can go back to this command we're
doing the similar resizing that we did
to the spheres of the water so let's
change ligand water to magnesium and
it's it's bigger it has a larger van der
Waals surface so let's just make this
one and so we've modified the one atom
type rebuild and we need to this is
showing I don't know what the
representation here is with with the
pretty preset but let's show the sphere
and now that's a nice size it shows that
it's a larger metal ion and it's
surrounded by these water molecules and
you can play with these sizes if you
don't like how this looks you can make
the water a little bit smaller all you
need to do is change this right here and
we could resize things so if you don't
like how this looks that's fine go ahead
and do something better okay now I think
we've done a lot of work I think this
looks pretty pretty good let's get all
the ligands in view and let's store this
as a scene so we want to use PI mole to
tell us how these ligands are binding in
the active site so now we're going to do
a quick thing that'll allow us to see
that so go to actions next to ligands
here find polar contacts to any atoms so
this is pretty busy but we're gonna
utilize this to make a really nice image
that tells us some good information so
if we look over here on our molecule we
have a phosphate so that phosphate is
binding to a few residues and maybe
we're really interested in highlighting
the way that this is interacting with
the amino acids so we can see we have
some contacts of the phosphate two water
molecules so a hydrogen bond with those
and we also have interactions with some
residues so with histidine which is
potentially charged in the body we have
some arginine residues which are always
charged and so these are interacting
with the phosphate to stabilize it so
this is an ionic interaction Hugh's so
we're going to go to wizard and turn on
the measurement wizard and we're going
to measure distances and
let's not create a new object because
that'll create every time we measure
we'll get a new measurement here let's
merge with previous since we're trying
to show just one type of interaction
here so now I want to since I already
have the polar contacts up I can just
kind of trace them and so I got a click
on my first atom and then I'm gonna
click on my second atom so we got a
measurement of two point seven angstroms
here we've got an ionic interaction
going on right here so let's click here
and here so that's three point five
that's a little bit further out and then
we have these the histidine up here we
want to show this interacting and let's
just show one of the representative
interactions we don't need to show both
of these primal shows us a lot but we
get the story with just one interaction
and not make our image too busy so click
on histidine click right here and yeah
we've got some uh polar contact shown
now let's rename this and we can turn
off all of the ligand polar contacts and
really just highlight these interactions
going on here now if you are preparing
this image for a publication or
something like that you know journal
articles are white so it's important to
be able to change our background and so
we can go to display background change
that to white and fortunately our labels
change to black so we can see them and
we'll want to orient this in a nice way
that we can really see what's going on
and see the interactions oh that's
looking good so see I can see the whole
side chain here that this isn't arginine
I can see that here as well we see
histidine we get there the gist of the
sugar this is obscuring it a little I
don't know if I could make that and I
liked it better before that's that's
okay and maybe we think that these
measurements are a little bit light
against our white background so we'll
take our interactions color
maybe this medium gray this is a really
nice image and I don't want to lose it
so we're going to store it as a scene
and now let me show you why scenes are
so important so you know the we all have
this moment we're going to recolor
something maybe we're like magenta
doesn't have a good contrast with the
red so I should recolor my ligands but
somehow you end up or maybe you want to
recolor the protein you end up just like
one thing above this is so small so we
go to one pfk and say oh I'm just gonna
color my ligands all one color for right
now I'm not going to use CPK coloring we
hit Orange and we've lost all the work
that we've done but we haven't because
we were using scenes go ahead and click
on scene five everything comes back we
can navigate through our scenes to show
all of the water molecules in the active
site we can zoom out a little further we
can go back to our initial
representation of our protein and show
all of that coloring of the original
pretty preset that we used I hope you'll
join me next Monday for the next video
in this series and that if you like this
video you leave me a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel if you want to
learn more primal biochemistry and
organic chemistry